voici revenu
mais oui vous connaissez bien sûr on est
à l'école ensemble avant elle et quand
je suis parti très bon robert bonsoir
bonsoir vouliez prix lui pourquoi après
cash ou la joie nice après qu'elle
soulage la nuit bon robert bonsoir
d'être là donc on peut dire que vous en
tous les cas on va faire un petit tour
de vis comme ça parce qu'on vous entends
souvent raison qu'il sortait dans notre
rôle va donc maintenant on peut le dire
beyrouth avec esmeralda mais chaque
faille est alors on peut dire que vous
vous avez eu la chance d'avoir des
parents communistes allaient j'entends
alors là on va voir une photo de vous
avec votre père justement est ce qu'on
peut voir la photo de robert hue avec
séparer de mon père mais si le père noël
oui ah ouais parce que je croyais à
cause de la barre c'est à la sortie de
l'école saint joseph il est environ
roger qu'il a une barbe effet ford
alors robert j'avais une mèche à la fin
je n'ai plus mal on va en parler alors
chez vous comme ces petits vous dites
que on avait pas la télé pour le
couronnement d'elizabeth 2 mai pour la
visite de khrouchtchev en france quoi
salut mon âge de la télé pour la vis de
khrouchtchev vous avez vraiment été
levées là dedans
objet du judo alors on va voir une photo
de vous en judokas voilà vous avez déjà
le petit bout
vous avez connu il est à droite ribéry
est à droite et on voit très bien que
déjà très branché robert rouge la
ceinture noire alors donc en 62 après
sharon vous rentrez aux jeunesses
communistes en 64 à l'école du parti se
dire quand même que vous êtes un peu
sorti de nulle part mais en fait depuis
64 était en train de bosser quand même
un déjà et en 99 aujourd'hui vous êtes
secrétaire général et député maire de
montigny les cormeilles et d'argenteuil
parce que ouais ma vie n'est pas dans la
même circonscription a lâché quelque
chose d'un peu moins drôle au sujet de
montigny-lès-cormeilles dans le parisien
du 2 février vous déclarer je suis pas
hostile à l'éloignement des sauvageons
c'est à dire ces décès du chauffeur pour
la robert sauvage ou non mais attendez
c'est vous qui dites oui mais
chevènement et j'ai dit que je n'étais
pas contre l'éloignement de deux jeunes
qui [ __ ] la pagaille dans certains
quartiers mais le formule sauvageons ne
plaît pas bon pour l'éloignement des
mets quelques avantages préventifs pas
je n'aime pas trop la répression quand
elle est nécessaire il faut
naturellement l'employé mais sinon je
suis pas trop bas alors où on est mais
après c'est ça alors en 80 déjà ce qu'il
faut dire que j'ai eu un petit souci
parce que vous étiez allé manifester
sous les sous les fenêtres d'une famille
immigrée d'origine marocaine qui était
accusé de trafic de drogue et bernard
henri lévy notre grand penseur nationale
avait parlé de fascisme à la française
dans ce médecin oui je me souviens de
cette formule qui était complètement
déplacé à mon avis je comme mr
effectivement j'avais réagi à plusieurs
morts dans la ville où j'étais et puis
dans les villes voisines de la drogue
c'était pas d'ailleurs forcément de la
droite dure il y avait des jeunes qui
erraient prix du triclosan enfin plein
de choses et ça m'avait bouleversé à
l'époque j'avais réagi vous étiez allé
manifester sous les fenêtres des games
assez pauvre et celle d'arrivée
alors vous avez déjà vais manifester
parce que je pense qu'effectivement
c'est une affaire qui appelle une
réaction de la société
ouais c'était effectivement peut-être
que je me tais je devais avant l'heure
mais bon enfin cela dit ça a fait notre
succès parce que marcher georges
marchais était venu faire le premier
meeting de la campagne présidentielle
chez vous et finalement c'est comme ça
que vous êtes devenu l'icône pas faire
vraiment un en arrière à course
vous disiez à l'époque les drogués sont
pas en état de faire la révolution c'est
pour ça que ça vous ça c'est des
formules formellement d'accord mais on a
beaucoup disserté là dessus c'est pas
bon je veux bien qu'on parle de cette du
rapport à l'avant les deux choses m'ont
offert la drogue c'est bon non mais ça
ça me gêne pas parce que ma réaction
n'était pas par rapport à ces jeunes
s'étaient c'était le problème de la
drogue qui commençait déjà à pourrir les
cités à mon avis si à l'époque déjà nous
avions pris à bras le corps cette
question et en posant les problèmes de
la société parce que c'est pas la drogue
est un effet donne une crise qui existe
et danser dans ces quartiers difficiles
il y avait effectivement déjà la
diffusion une diffusion parallèle pour
l'âme ce qu'il y a pas que dans les
quartiers difficiles
oui c'est ouais vous êtes vous seriez
pour la légalisation des drogues douces
n'ont le droit parce que je mène le
classement
je crois que il y à un risque réel de de
passer ensuite à la drogue dure donc je
ne suis pas d'accord
même si par ailleurs je vois bien qu'il
ya d'autres fléaux
on parle toujours de l'alcool et il faut
les combattre mais en même temps je ne
suis pas pour la légalisation wallace et
ses galères n'était sans appel pour moi
en tous les corps non mais très bien
tout le monde était un petit peu déçue
sur le plateau pas du tout à bon rythme
et de casser l'ambiance je pense ce
qu'il dit oui je pense que
les drogues douces amène pas forcément
donc dur c'est ça et que au lieu de
laisser les jeunes gens fumer du pneu et
de la et de l'huile fermenté n'importe
quoi de vidange je sais pas si c'est pas
ça qui leur fait plus de mal que l'heure
est grave
il est né dans il est né dans le coco et
non mais c'est vrai qu'on passe pas
forcément aux drogues dures mais on peut
il passer donc et puis moi j'ai bien vu
durable le rapport entre drogues douces
ensuite d'autres produits effectivement
vous avez réservé c'est un problème
difficile
bernard aubert est pas tant la
dépénalisation alors comme ça on le sait
qu'elle joue vous êtes pour ou contre
moi ça me va pas
non mais vous me vexez pas du tout alors
quand vous faisiez du robinet trempette
et quand vos choix ah oui les banquiers
du rock'n'roll
robert hue convié du rock'n'roll où on
peut voir une photo de robert hue à
l'époque oui c'est du rock and roll
voilà donc ça s'appelait c'est un jour
parce c'est lé rapport comment je sais
les rapaces c'est très très bien et le
nom les rapaces a été trouvé par vous
derrière lui ses skis pour un communiste
est très fort parce qu'après vous êtes
vous avez passé votre vie à combattre
les rapaces ans passés il y avait des
bouts tour l'époque les pirates ça
existe toujours
oui le votre batteur notre bassiste
j'aurais lydie que vous chantiez pas
très bien mais que vous étiez agressif
sur scène
ah oui cgt à ces révoltés sur scène sur
votre rêve incarné well as raison
révolté plus qu'énervé dans sept à cette
époque d'ailleurs la sete
vol du rock and roll des groupes des
jeunes avec tous des groupes moi
j'allais au golf-drouot enfin c'était
c'était quelque chose que l'on sait
c'est une époque bénie toujours mélangé
pas énervé révolter mais non au
contraire au jour d'aujourd'hui quand on
met un peu révolté on dit souvent qu'il
est ému je sais quoi de faire alors j'ai
testé la beta alors alors robert à
l'époque vous aviez vous allez vous
rêviez d'aller au golf mais vous n'avez
pas assez d'argent pour vous acheter du
matériel du matos oui c'était l'egypte
sonne et fender ça coûte cher et donc je
vais pas me souvenais les chansons que
vous sentiez à l'époque quelques-unes
mais bon s'il voit peu le large en
suivait par exemple avec jean vincent
hein c'est très vieux a essayé quand
même bon alors de millery vous vous
donniez des rythmes attention un marine
bébé vibre à louplande me baby bat
pauline she's my baby baby baby voilà
j'espère pour lui qu'il aura plus de
voix aux européennes
en tous les cas ça barde à vous ça donne
envie
oui ça donne envie de abc ne sera pas
belges allaient voter pour arlette mais
maintenant je me demande je suis en
train de changer d'avis aujourd'hui les
messieurs c'est une bombe encore deux
émissions en bravant la cage vient nous
chanter souchon arlette qu'on va craquer
mais moi on peut chanter l'inter à ça je
la connais salut à vous l'avez garder ça
alors à vous avez gagné
attendez vous êtes en pleine mutation
robert à je comprends plus rien à
l'international
on garde alors parce que vous êtes ans
est un mutant c'est les mecs lazaron
c'est d'être mieux communiste donc
l'international
vous avez gardé l'intérieur dont il ya
deux trucs que vous avez gardé en fait
c'est la faucille et le marteau elle a
une maîtrise tsunade marché vous avez
gardé de regarder la faucille et le
marteau à la une de l'humanité vous avez
gardé l'international c'est vrai ça
l'international du show note qu'il n'est
pas chanter avec moi quand même et je
sais pas l'intérêt d'aller mal à lui
et si la bourbre en nous c'est demain
l'international français mardi
voilà demi royalistes alors justement va
passer on va repasser un succès au pc
vous êtes ce que vous appelez en ce
moment les galets votre bouquin là que
je montre à la caméra qui s'appelle
robert hue un nouveau projet en fait ils
essuient d'avant déjà et ça c'est le
dernier
voilà est ce que tout le monde a bien vu
très bien vous êtes pour la mutation
c'est ça c'est à dire que maintenant
vous êtes un petit peu pour non pas le
renversement du capitalisme mais le
dépassement du capitalisme ou y je
voulais plus renverser le capitalisme
en tous les cas je ne veux pas le
l'aménager voyez la différence qu'il y
avait qu on la démarche ci a democrat
moi je ne suis pas pour l'encadrer je ne
suis pas pour la mairie je suis vraiment
pour changer le système et donc le
dépasser l'idée de rupture brutale c'est
vrai que on a vu que ça se décrétait pas
de supprimer le capitalisme et à l'état
de pays qui aujourd'hui ont disparu
entre tous les temps en tant que système
à l'est qui avait dit on met un terme au
capitalisme mais c'est pas de le décider
de décréter enfin processus alors je
sais pas mais par exemple en ce moment
air france est en train d'être
privatisée avec un ministre communiste
qui s'appelle crise et non une
participation au capital
non la prise de partie face aux capitals
ne participe à manger sainement de la
question à vous poser par rapport à ça
la première est ce que tu une question
générale sur les privatisations est ce
que quand une société nationale est
privatisée est ce que l'argent devrait
pas être donné aux contribuables qui ont
financé ce truc là
en tous les cas je pense qu'il faut pas
nationalisées du tout fin privatisée par
non du tout le lapsus est bien est
significatif non il est clair
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il ya trop de
privatisation ouais il y avait conclu un
engagement de prix de ne pas privatiser
certains grands services
certains groupes et ils sont encore
demandé au gouvernement d'accélérer le
rythme du changement vous demandez pas
qui est de plus en plus dans les valises
à sion pas d'une privatisation est par
contre des réformes de structures
importantes qui permettent d'orienter
l'argent autrement déjà
entre nous vous acceptez quand même que
air france soit pas disons privatisées
mais qui une participation du privé au
capital est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un
peu le gorbatchev français ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu le pourquoi il est
écouté
c'est pas mal est-ce que j'ai pas un peu
le syndic de feuilles de bambou vient il
il y à une initiation en partant du
parti communiste mais pour rester
communiste si bien clair c'est pas je ne
veux pas devenir social démocrate var
donc je prends la paire intéressant à
faire un test qui intéressera de tram et
boehringer vous préférez fidel castro ou
tony blair
je préfère fidel castro à bien les
égards on vient à cuba on peut pas
m'accuser d'anticommunisme primaire
sérieusement pas vous pensez que tout va
bien
non non non je pensais qu'il est
suffisant vient d'un peuple qui cette
qui sait lire écrire qui est un peuple
admirable qui est un des peuples les
plus magnifique que j'ai pu croiser
je suis pas vous vous trouvez pas qu'il
ya beaucoup d'uniformes dans là je
trouve que la démocratie ça va pas ça
c'est clair
mais c'est en même temps en même temps
en même temps je suis allé à cuba il ya
un an j'ai pas vu plus uniforme
qu'ailleurs il reste que moi j'en viens
à ibb on va donc je ne sais pas je
reviens pas moi il ya trop de risques et
week-end dernier deux mois que c'est
clair ce qui est clair c'est que je ne
fais qu tivement sur les questions de
démocratie je pense qu'il a vraiment un
grand prend à faire il reste que je
partage aussi le point de vue qui me
semble être le monde c'est-à-dire ce
blocus que subit ce peuple est assez
terrifiant et je pense que cette petite
île et son peuple ne menace pas le grand
leader américain à côté donc je suis
pour que de ce point de vue on aime
moins le blocus en allemagne mais pour
vous le problème c'est le blocus bon
alors les européennes on va terminer que
les européennes les pardons quoi oui
c'est vrai résumé robert donc les
européens seulement de recul ce que vous
êtes pour vous êtes pour la double
parité c'est à dire une femme communisme
que la thèse a fait en partie communiste
vous demandez à risque moi je peux les
aider beaucoup vous êtes la tva c'est
pas mal vous êtes pour aux européennes
donc votre lycée double parité
homme-femme et communistes non
communiste alors vous avez fodé sylla
avait roland castro prises et a pris à
jeun il aurait été bien oui j'ai pensé à
prendre en main il était même d'accord
mais je crois qu'il faut que bon ça
pourrait se faire ouais c'est pas c'est
pas du financement bouclé mais quand je
ne prends pas que en même temps une
faille trop mélanger les camps braouezec
le député maire de saint-denis parle de
liste attrape-tout your pc c'est un anti
east non non je ne prends pas mais qu'on
abhorre les pattes rapetou braouzec le
sait s'il est attrape-tout allierait de
de jean pierre chevènement un pull in
c'est pas le cas moi j'ai noté un peu la
première européenne c'est compliqué il y
aura des noms communiste sur la liste
communiste y aura des gens de gauche sur
la liste pasqua une fille le pen sur la
liste maigret c'est pas un peu le bordel
l'europe quand même hein je ne crois pas
en moins tous les corses qui vont dans
le parti comme il parle pour moi il est
évident que nous avons osé faire ce que
aucun autre parti n'a fait il y à 50%
des sièges sur cette liste qui sont
offerts en fait dix points du nom connu
pour des non communiste et j'ajoute pas
seulement dans la parité sur la liste
parce qu'on pourrait faire une partie
soliste mais au niveau des élus dire bon
là sur les sur les 10 premiers ou douze
premiers par exemple il y aura sinon
communiste dans l'ue et si communiste
ceux ci et puis des saints dans le
canard enchaîné qui essayait de lambres
paru cette semaine mercredi on voit
robert hue est dit il y aurait même sur
notre registre des communistes aux
livres à 50%
vous avez dit ça c'est plus grave vous
avez dit je n'étais pas le gars qui
voyait clair avant les autres oui c'est
vrai c'est à dire que le goulag vous
saviez pas je suis pas dit ça j'ai dit
dieu sinon c'est pas du tout ça
et tous ceux qui disent aujourd'hui je
savais et je mais je ne pouvais pas
faire et c'est pas la phrase de robert
oui je la trouve plutôt n'était pas le
gars qui voyait clair avant les war se
disent tous ces lots dénombre way pour
tous et bienvenue à reconnaître souvenir
pendant la guerre il ya plein de mecs
qui jouent on savait pas aussi je trouve
plutôt habile très bête de scène robert
reçu tellement il a une bonne bouille
bien dire ses sympathies il l'a fait
exprès alors là on va et moi je dois y
venir à cette bonne bouille parce que on
va pas les faux culs et les hypocrites
je sais que moi je n'ai pas de sympathie
pour le front national est loin de là et
bien au contraire
et j'en aurais plutôt pour vous monsieur
et on sait que le pen vous a traité le
nain de jardin et tout ça et c'est non
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai et c'est
plutôt sympathique finalement 1 n'a pas
fait exprès
voilà les croyais est méchant c'est sa
beauté sa côté joyeux après avoir été
dans tous les jardins je veux être dans
toutes les urnes c'était évident
mieux pas être agent est ce qu'il vaut
mieux être agent de kb jardin ou du kgb
j'aime bien la de crouch assez bien vous
savez qu'on va passer aux femmes vous
allez rester avec nous un pied cachou
vous reste avec nous ça faisait plus
fâché non ça va aller mais voilà je sais
pas si vous êtes au crash et un
ukrainien blanche neige
un mécénat tranquille et si longtemps de
côté ses abords